i've still got lots to learn so i'm off
to try
a traditional christmas dish that i hear
tastes
much better than it smells now trust me
i want to get the best of christopher
and i'm up here to meet two guys who
make this amazing delicacy
that can only be found here
first of all i'm excited to see and
taste this incredible delicacy
and it's rock fish rockfish fisk
frogfisk
fisk fisk rock fisk rock face rock
rock fish no okay
after what seems like hours of saying
the same thing back and forth
barnstein and his nephew magnus show me
how they make the crown jewel
of their family business fermented fish
why smell no it's strong
is that normal that's strong trout and
what is that one there this is arctic
shell arctic char
and how long do you cure it for it's in
for three months
bloody hell so you pack it with salt
yeah and then sugar as well sugar so it
cures it
yeah exactly and how old is this method
dates back to the viking age
now it's more popular than ever shall we
first you put salt in the belly like
this and you just put them in the bucket
and then it's heads tails head tails all
the way
through opposite yeah and you build
exactly
sounds pretty straightforward also i
thought but the rec fisk master
is not impressed too much too much
too much less salt how's that one uncle
ah good
good thank god for that i've never seen
this method before like this
only here in railroads and so it
literally is indigenous to this area
it is we're very proud it's very popular
especially
around christmas oh no no no
no no no no a little more no more
you have to use your wrists
so that's it ah perfect
man your uncle's amazing do you ever
upset him yeah a lot of times
yeah he's better good good better he's
happy now he's been a little bit tough
for me
yeah i've been for with me for 10 years
as well he's a proper viking
i'm dying to taste it oh there it is
that's the dream
wow that's it there
yeah it's strong there's this cross
between a sort of cured salmon but with
a vacheron cheese it was so strong
very acidic yeah this is not very strong
that's not very strong no
let's try a stronger one no stop it
let's try it yeah stronger than that
let's try our special christmas patch
bloody hell
i'm worried that special in this case is
not a good thing
so what's special about this batch we
have had it in the barrel for a longer
amount of time
now oh my god the smell of that bloody
hell
it doesn't look very appetizing the
smell gets stronger the farther down the
bucket you go bloody hell seriously
oh my god it's as sticky as
you don't eat this do you oh my god
you like that smell yes oh no
no look at the juice
the color of the juice that's the right
texture can you can you cut that
this is a joke oh my lord
oh my god it's like putty why is this so
a special rare delicacy when it stinks
you should not think about the smell
it's the flavor
oh
no no no that's the right texture
want to see more from my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips